the divisions last expansion is in the  works  but we just got a sneak peek thanks to a  live stream I'm Tony and this gamespot  news update is ready to fire  last stand includes both pvp and PVE and  adds new dark zones to the game the new  zones DZ seven eight and nine are said  to give more freedom of exploration  you'll be able to get there from DZ six  since it's one contiguous space but the  expansion also adds fast travel between  DZ checkpoints as for PvP Last Stand is  an 8 v8 mode with full matchmaking  support Last Stand doesn't have a  confirmed release date yet but it'll  launch on ps4 Xbox one and PC  simultaneously alongside update 1.6 a  new incursion is also coming with the  expansion but we don't know much about  that yet to keep up with all the latest  on the division you're already in the  right place